well
[Music]
how are you, cristian cásseres greets you with
his brief news now in
spanish a fire was reported on
friday in a house near downtown
las vegas on 23rd street and bonanza
shortly after 3 in the morning the
fire department  they said that no one was
hurt and that they managed to control the fire
quickly the cause of the incident is still
under investigation
a woman faces murder charges
after an arson fire it is reported
that a woman set fire to a bed and
another died due to this incident the
judge denied her  a bail hp levels on
thursday police say you smell
the fire started during an
argument inside a trailer home
near mojave and tauste on
wednesday the coroner's office revealed
the identity of the victim as gene
barry who are over the age of 39
to  state level authorities
say kobe cases reached their highest
level this month however cases
are declining even though the rate
transmission remains high
kobe 19 testing sites no longer
have long waits as
home tests are already arriving
to residents and we close this report
with a look at temperatures
we will have sunny skies with highs in
the  60 degrees for Friday we will see
some clouds for this weekend
but Sunday will be a sunny one
next week we will have strong winds
in the valley I am cristian cásseres with your
brief informative of them now Spanish
good day
[Music]